I'm gonna do it I'm gonna say the end
we're gonna do it I'm gonna pull out my
meat scepter hello there it looks down
shyly goes out me it's time to review
red edge yeah green Tex is when people
read funny stories and confessions in a
format on tumblr as an example we have
this one birthday is our New Year family
for god friends forgot sad and Nintendo
emails me happy birthday feel better and
play some Smash Bros Thank You Nintendo
pick related wholesome story it's pretty
much that level of apathetic most of
them it's kinda like what did we do last
time there's no meat sectors as far as
I'm concerned so I bought I can't do
this I'm sorry seven years old
twin-brother does parents don't let me
go to his funeral tell me what it is
where it is tells me it would be
inappropriate to be there as it could
confuse people Jesus Christ what you
can't go to your brother's funeral
because you look like people would be
confused what what are you doing here
it's a miracle
okay wait 10 out of 10 my mom died once
oh right they in the comments mom mom
dad wants fu you bro just once though go
to YMCA family showers see naked
four-year-old
grew up to be a Pettit Wow what the hell
is this same go
the year is 2020 Trump is reelected not
again immediate immediately declares war
on Vietnam not again
and Vietnam 2.0 thousands of Gen Z kids
are drafted in the military few months
later the rice farmer in Vietnam start
hearing lil yachty playing in the
distance to the sound of rotary engines
helicopter start flying over me
Gucci gang starts blasting from the
helicopter speakers oh an area around me
gets napalm choppers drop off enemy
troops get smoked by a 17 year old with
a bigger rig sticker on the side of his
helmet he the support and I dance over
my body
then you need to embrace goddamn Vietnam
I'm sorry that's gotta be the absolute
worst way to die possible I might be too
old how do you eat someone you throw
them yee-yee anonymous says be me
there's a good start
surgeon 35 our operation do it perfectly
with no mistakes everyone thanks God but
I mean Here I am you know with a god
complex surgery that's like as if people
Thank You Tube for our videos thank you
you too thank you YouTube thank you so
much everyone Thank You Tube in the chat
be me 18 new at this school gym class
I'm a pretty decent looking guy I look
good in sports because my pecs okay we
get to play dodge ball FBS play for a
bit trying to show off for this cutie
okay yeah sure well ping dodgeball is
that how you got ladies in the in this
school she's into me she's she's on the
other team how does he know that she's
into him she throws at me dodge grabs
ball throw it at some dude with the
force of a thousand suns I miss him
hit the cutie in the face
are you kidding me God JP her nose is
bleeding
teeth through her lip she's crying I
can't cross the line to help her because
the rules I ain't losing the game
spaghetti every spaghetti and that's how
I Met Your Mother
beaten watching Scooby door what dfw
Velma's sexy dark stroking my junk
through the blanket oh you're so good
that PNG huh Phillip volcano roughly in
my lord scepter I knew it yeah no stop
Scouts Koopa do as a busload start doing
on the rig mom thinks I really like
scooby-doo mom bought me all season
scooby-doo for Christmas live in
Virginia move to North Carolina see you
later
Virginians Virginians like all the
people who make these yes exactly
Wow put the words out of my mouth this
is not my story but one I had seen like
seven months ago have spider bro s do
you do
eats random bugs and [ __ ] in my kitchen
once killed a mouse damn we live happily
together for a few months one night go
to bars and pick up girl
bring girl home and end up heading to my
bedroom
spider bro is on wall go screams runs
home get so angry I kill spider bro for
denying me my needs no spider bro
finds out from friend couple days later
that the girl had herpes spider broad
knew my ladder broke and spider broad
knew he was trying to protect bro don't
do it mate so today for the first time
my little toddler finally counted put in
Wow my god
alright everyone was celebrating saying
how proud they are and in my in my kid
Wow okay yeah we got weird not in your
grammar suddenly been sharp Oh kicks
open the door wait Ben who I don't know
the man was chaperone chaperone who the
same b20 heard you can f watermelons
vice personal watermelon what does that
even mean this is a hell all water bills
you bout our cuts a round hole starts
effing watermelon took like 40 minutes
wait to cut not all-around watermelon
yeah I I don't want to know probably
though not much better than fapping felt
shame buried melon in shallow grave come
summertime melon screw in the backyard
family eats them oh no you don't you
don't want it any melon no why aren't
you having them watermelons delicious oh
it's so juicy this personal watermelon
the / it tastes person girl looks at me
the image really isn't what the image of
me is now pulsing through her neurons
technically an insider later versions
[Music]
I did it 20 Fiat formal basically prom
in college dress great look great my
date looks great she's the love of my
life
gotta try and impress her pulls out all
the stops expensive liquor excellent
steak dance the night away I think we're
in love wake up the next day really
drunk have to poop decide to hold the
head till we get back to school not a
long drive drunk driving back to Philly
moving faster than when will started
making trouble in his neighborhood I
need to poop butt cheeks clench harder
than a Penn State locker room alcohol
has made me loose it's hard to squeeze
grit my teeth not gonna make it back to
school go on wait
I don't think oh it was drunk driving
this was this was the last message he
sent before he ran off the road oh this
is this is a lesson for all of you who
don't put you butt cheeks and Raph just
poop
let it go damn just let it go
embracing figures at Pompeii could have
been gay lovers after scan reveals
they're both men beat me drinking wine
with best bro served 10 years and army
together what saved my life once named
my son after the guy mountain frickin
explodes von Hausen hide for shelter
give each other one last bro hug ash
burns us both 1900 years later get found
a little gay boys not girly said no homo
what happened I wanted to be clear the
one thing it's so typical as well like
Oh two people they must have been gay
lovers there were both boys they were
gay I've been playing Red Dead - all day
every day for a week Street
how'd you actually leave the house for a
groceries etc I live in a at a college
so I actually had to do things for
myself what decide to try to be more
like Arthur Morgan I guess not the guy
from Red Dead yes the main character
okay about to walk past a guy in the
street will say the first car boyish
thing that comes to my head when I pass
him approached him hey sexy that's gas
Calif F caliber CD thing no howdy
partner no nothing just hey sexy Hey and
then I slapped his ass wrote him off
this sunset seventeen family try to get
a boat in start to hear whisper in my
ear look behind me neither goes into my
throat and I get knocked down
wake up I'm tied to a chair look around
see then chef Hugo Boss bat out hit me
so hard I can't move takes the baby out
no pain killer says lib tart I would
raise this baby bleed and die in the
middle of nowhere all I see is ben
shapiro chant a magic spell and the baby
grows into a clone of [ __ ]
third grade grew up with dad had an
absentee mom told me to hit people back
if they hit me first
didn't tell all right this should be
good didn't tell me it doesn't apply to
girls Jesus oh this should be doing in
class a roast he talks about air to me
for no reason
politely told Rosie stop I don't know a
girl apparently she evently shoves me it
did big slam on in her face flies across
the room knocked unconscious with her
skull cracked and starting to bleed
Christ's class run away in fear of me
principal comes down screams at me and
calls the cops got fired later that day
it was third grade please much like for
spider brooch check out Ken for some
reason if you want to I got meat scepter
jokes and as always broke paste you
ready for this can dooba dooba do
you want pyramids we got them Oh you're
into casos huh we got you covered baby
you want some bets easy we got it all
this game is still relevant goddamn it
[Music]